well the r t General Secretary Mick
Lynch joins me now a very good morning
to you Mick Lynch first of all just how
much support do you expect to have for
the walkout today just how disruptive
will this strike be
well our members will be out all over
the country they'll be on picket lines
up and down the rail network we've had a
very strong mandate to renew our action
in the last week or so a nine to one
vote on a heavy turnout
so our members are up and down the
picket lines taking the action as
instructed by the union and has voted
for by them
and so the action is solid and it will
be as long as this campaign goes on
people watching will know that this
dispute has been going on for a long
time how close are you now to a
resolution
well we had an offer put to us the
second or third offer I think in this
this process which we have declined to
accept because
the the stipulations that were put on it
were not acceptable to our people we had
a good conversation about that
throughout the union so we're looking
for a fresh offer from the company we're
looking for
a new set of negotiations to start we
haven't got a settlement for the drivers
as you saw yesterday with the agilef
strike and we haven't got that for the
other grades in the rmt strikes as well
so
there's there's a lot of anger in the
rail industry at the minute both unions
are still campaigning they're members of
voting in heavy numbers to continue the
action so there's a lot of strength for
feeling and it's up to the government to
unblock this this dispute because they
they have the final say on what is
proposed at the table in their contracts
with these companies they stipulate what
the negotiating position is
they stipulate what the uh what the
offers are and those offers simply
aren't good enough at the minute they
don't recognize the cost of living
crisis where inflation has gone and what
they want from our members in terms of
giving up their terms and conditions are
simply not acceptable so there's a long
way to go but we are available for
dialogue and negotiation at any time
they want you to put this latest offer
to a ballot of members why aren't you
doing that
because it's not acceptable it doesn't
meet the the demands in the dispute they
know that they knew knew that when it
was offered and certainly when they
clarified what they meant by it what
they want us to do is call off the
dispute and then go into another set of
negotiations without any leverage at the
table we simply can't do that you don't
disarm yourself halfway through a
campaign and they're asking us to call
off all our actions to declare that the
dispute is over when only half of the
issues have been negotiated so that's
not possible we're prepared to talk to
them and we're prepared to go into a
process but we're not prepared to call
off all of our action and declare the
dispute over when the issues have not
been settled so they've put a lot of
money into this dispute they've spent
over 1.25 billion on this dispute and
they've lost that money for the economy
and for the railway based on a Dogma
what we need is a practical solution to
the dispute so that we can get the
railways back to normal and the
government needs to show a bit of Good
Will and flexibility and stop wasting
the Public's money on this campaign
propping up private sector train
operators while they're making profit
our members are losing money and the
public are disrupted so we need a change
of stance from the government
immediately
so what are the key difference in this
dispute from the one with network rail
where you did ballot members and yet
you're not on this one so what are the
differences
well in network rail they made an
improved offer it's not the same offer
the drivers have only been off at eight
percent
over these two years and they haven't
had a pay rise for four years our
members have been offered nine percent
over those four years because we haven't
had a pay deal for such a long time
but in this one they are saying to us we
have to go into another round of
negotiations after we declared the
dispute over so what the demand was two
weeks ago was that we say that the
dispute has been concluded when the
issues have not been negotiated whereas
in network rail the issues were settled
they moved forward with their
modernizing maintenance plan they
enhanced the offer in cash terms so it's
a superior offer to the one that's
available to train operating companies
they put a travel facilities deal in it
and there were new contracts of
employment for many of our members that
have got the potential to improve their
earnings over the rest of their career
so it's a completely different offer for
Network Rail and it was a different
picture the network rail moves in a way
that our members could accept but the
train operating companies have not been
allowed to do that by the government
okay so if the train companies drop the
request to get rid of the your stripe
mandate would you put that to the to the
ballot is the rest of the deal sound
essentially
well the devil's no because it's the
network rail deal was a better deal it
had more cash in the offer than this one
it's in the technicalities of the way
the deal works so what we need to do is
get around the table and get a document
written down in a way that is clear it
was unclear in its first version and
that broke down because of the
interpretation so we'll be talking to
the companies next next week to see if
they want to get around the table and
fresh out a deal if we get a deal that
is clear in its meaning and we're
allowed to keep our or unable to keep
our mandate going so that we've got
leverage at the negotiating table
perhaps we can move forward but the
devil's always in the detail of these
documents and we'll have to see what it
says to see if we can move forward but
what's going on at the moment is the
government is wasting everybody's time
and money rather than allowing the
companies to negotiate and get a
reasonable Prospect in a deal
everybody's been put in a straight
jacket really so that we can't move this
dispute forward so hopefully we can do
that in the next week or two okay well
micklin we appreciate your time this
morning thanks very much indeed